hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay
um still don't know why I came here I
don't think I found what I needed
who's dropping pipes hit hey hey hey up
banging nope didn't need that
wait still a bullet alright um we got
here okay finally getting somewhere I
need to go
oh no no gimme gimme
I guess I had a key somewhere I don't
know where upgradable stuff I like
upgradable stuff it's one of my favorite
game mechanics the feeling that you're
doing something to make yourself
progress all right what do we got ah ba
ba ba ba hitpoints don't need hit points
err there seem to be recharge stations
for the stasis module so I'm gonna guess
that I don't need it okay damage your
capacity damaging capacity uh damage
yeah else all right let's see oh so much
more damage
Oh power node Oh gimme gimme goob
aha lag why lag my computer is so epic
it should not be lagging mmm no no no
okay Oh more damage oh damn it no Jason
node okay um I guess I can do capacity
why not why not
sounds good to me alright let's see yeah
hello guessing the red ones are locked
good guess up another medpac there I go
through the arduous process of dropping
one and picking up the medium one oh hey
nope no you still dead
yeah actually good hi
right now balls get out of here you stay
dead buddy Oh trust in what what what oh
hey yours but I'm not trusting any of
you anymore
you just stay dead you stay dead forever
oh oh I can't stop I'm so stupid I tried
I'm a I bet thank her and stop e Tommy
stop I bet I lose a bad habit of jumping
in other games that I try to jump I
can't jump in this game mmm and ice
Dappy toffee stompy squish squish squish
I think it's dead no I saw some movement
ha all right
I think it's appropriately dead okay
movin on am I going the right way I I
don't even know I can't tell
hi ah how do memo Hey
I've upgraded damaging capacity can't
touch this
nope nothing I got something good get
shut up I don't trust you get stomped ah
just ah one more time get your head
crush yeah were those like worms
ooh that's grody gross uh so they're
like they got worms in them it's like
really gross I don't want to save I want
to pick up the ammo darn it darn
give me the ammo okay animals right
there
mo it's it's right there in front of
your face man it's it's it's right now
aren't it I can't get that mo
that's stupid all right where am I going
let's see okay I'm hearing whispers
whispers are never good
okay um there we go hello okay
yay I did something yay I'm such a good
engineer hello
Bing oh yeah
yay hey take me with you don't leave me
don't leave me here leave me the
quarantine just lifted whatever was in
the flight lounge must have left us
lucky for us
Isaac get back to the carry-on and prep
it for launch we'll find out what we can
from the bridge and meet you there
you got to be kidding me you're out of
your league Hammond this is suicide
we're going to lie on confidence in me
is really noted miss Daniels but I have
a mission to complete and that's exactly
what I am going to do yeah hard core
just get us out of here alive not only
is he the token black guy he is also the
gung-ho soldier he's like a double so
all right moving on I think I'm going
this way right yep
yeah I'll bring it on I'll bring it on
through there yup
hearing strange sounds don't know what
that's all about
run hi Hey
all right I definitely can feel the
atmosphere in these things
Oh oh I can ah I can stomp them I'm an
idiot how many bullets should I waste
uh-oh
Oh creepy creepy creepy creepy ah man
this game is quite creepy
the atmosphere is dank yeah okay
bring it on don't don't even try it No
Oh get out of here
yeah run away you so scared of me oh
yeah okay
all right hello hi I'm chasing you now
Oh who's chasing who come here come here
I'm gonna get you look at you oh yeah
run away run away bum I could have got
ya I'll let you go up back nope no nope
huh not even a little bit get our guy
are you dead
what's up hi hi questionable activities
ha I cut off your head nope
dead good are you dad you better be
you're dead
whoa what's that oh it's a claw don't
even try it don't even try it
oh so badass
okay um guy good computer nope good job
my bet
we're going to try to get huh all right
I do not cuz you're all gonna die anyway
I'm gonna be left here alone only for
save slots okay I'll just cycle through
them
I probably shouldn't save so much just
does not put you guys through all the
stops
I'll always save like once per episode
which means I'm gonna die a lot probably
do I need one of those oh I've got so
many health no I've got plenty of those
okay um yeah okay okay I'm going this
ship for lunch come here
ah Mele boom shoot it boom yeah it's
worth it to shoot it if you know it's
gonna give me ammo so oh hello oh hey
get out of here
nope nope nope nope hey hey it took like
two shots before to kill that guy why
did that one suddenly take a billion
yeah I somehow don't think this thing's
gonna you know fly what do I know I'm an
engineer maybe I can fix it load no
damage report oh hey whoa hey hey oh oh
get out of here get out get up oh yeah
that that makes sense
loading the damage report is the same as
loading high explosives into the like
cd-rom just shoving in there oh oh you
want some get some boom right in the
balls BAM boo hey don't crunch down what
are you doing trying to huddle balls I
don't know why but I'm really good at
hitting him right in the balls
oh hey what are you doing buying banging
Oh another one
bong Bing BAM boom bing bang e ball all
right aren't you dead just die yep
uh-huh just let me think
can you access the man computer Hey
kicking a body all the way down
it's no good there's an executive
lockdown of all primary systems without
the captain's authorization I can't
access that oh that's too bad
captain here he is Captain Benjamin a
theis location
medlab status deceased dead yes I can't
access that information find the captain
and you'll find his rig I won who's
gonna find the captain this computer
wide open famous Isaac I'm saying the
tram back to your location oh thank you
yep yep I got to do all the work
hope this is where they die bye-bye
it's nice knowing you gave me an
objective and then promptly died that's
how it goes in this game okay
I got a cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching hope you're enjoying
this the experience so far and I will
see you in the next part
bye-bye